what are your thoughts about if
coronavirus happen in 94 not today okay
so go to 94 no Facebook no YouTube not
even MySpace no Twitter no Friendster no
nothing no that's right you would be
struggling if there's no zoom
none of this stuff 94 News doesn't go
like this you don't just go all of a
sudden boom update update notification
notification notification if this
pandemic happened in 1994 how different
would have the people reacted to the way
media keep saying end of the world end
of the world and the door by the way
what's what happened we need to be
stopped using apocalyptic language okay
this is a media debt well I know that
but and they are being apocalyptic but I
wrote an article actually it's called
for El Al Arabiya
which is the US government's Arab
language news service for the Middle
East and North Africa they asked me to
write a column as a former AI D it's not
well known the United say people don't
know all good things they do around the
world but in that marib world AI D is
very well known
so they said would you is the former
administrator write something because
people don't know what's going on
they're afraid there's panic in the
Middle East and in North Africa and I
said sure so I wrote it and I said
there's they're too dangerous here one
is to understate the risk by dismissing
this and not listening to the experts
like dr. faux Qi and the other is to
suggest the apocalypse is upon us and
the world is about to end it's not about
to end this is nowhere near what it was
a 1918 where 5% of the world's
population died in six months we didn't
even know what a virus was then we're
just beginning to develop the germ
theory of disease okay they used to
think that it was a swamp gas and cause
illnesses and they would still they were
still bleeding people 100 years ago they
thought the the problem was too much
blood or there's something wrong with
your blood and they would bleed you as a
way of treating a disease that was a
hundred years so well we have a much
more advanced system now we have science
we know a lot more and we also know how
to produce vaccines we weren't producing
vaccines 125 years ago
we are now so an advanced medication you
know most of the drugs produced in the
19th century 20 there were jokes they
weren't serious back they hurt you if
took you so we have a much more advanced
system we don't and and that means we
can respond and the structures of
government are much more sophisticated
even though people get disgusted with
the government you know who's gonna be
the big solution of this people talk
about the Chinese model working in oh
that's baloney
the Chinese model is not a superior
model to our mo our model is highly
decentralized at the state and local
level most of the response is not taking
place at the federal level that's the
most visible because the news media from
its what the 50 governors are doing all
the mayors the boards of Selectmen in
New England ryu originally kind of came
from the county judges in texas they are
the ones who run the systems that we
actually connect with who runs the
school systems the federal government
doesn't run in fools how many
universities there right none
how many factories they run it's a
highly decentralized system and what's
amazing to me is if you watch what's
happening across the country people are
simply saying I see the threat I'm the
leader of an institution I want to
protect my people which is my job and
that's what they're doing across the
country so what's the big news
that is the best very good news that we
as a democracy are taking responsibility
at our own level not saying over in a
ways for someone from Washington tell us
how to fix this which is not a good idea
that's what we did yesterday we made a
list of people that have kids who they
can't find people and you know day care
to take care of them so they're working
from home and folks that are above 50
years old are working from home and then
we made a list of about anybody that's
pregnant anybody that has any kind of a
health based on the conversations that
they have they're all working from home
and you know we can have a few people
that are working from here we made that
decision yesterday so I agree with that
but the question I want to ask you in 94
what the US government in 94 have
reacted the way we are reacting today
would a amount of fear that's in people
right now because of social media would
happen would the steps and the way the
government reacted in 94 been the same
as it is today
actually is it so
Media that's driving some of the fear as
opposed to you know public health
authorities in in media because I think
I think a lot of actually the Director
General the World Health Organization
described before he declared a pandemic
that we are actually in an endemic and
so what we have now is we have an empire
100% oh so much misleading information
fear-mongering and trying to get anxiety
and worry in people and so it's it's
simple demmick and it's the fear is
actually much worse than covet and so
somehow we got to do a better that does
tell me that we need to do a better job
as a society and in in risk
communication and communicating you know
what the what the risks are and what
we're doing about it
and counter this this misinformation is
that is an implement media maybe we
would have been better in 94 without the
proliferation of social what I'm saying
[Music]